[Applauso]
la tecnologia di cui abbiamo sentito
parlare finora distruggerà più lavoro di
quella che sarà in grado di creare e fra
30 anni
vivremo ancora in un'economia basata sul
lavoro o saremmo passati ad un'economia
basata sul tempo libero diversi studiosi
nel mondo si stanno ponendo questi
interrogativi però in realtà nessuno sa
davvero nel 2050 quali saranno ancora i
lavori che esisteranno ancora e
soprattutto quali saranno i nuovi lavori
che nasceranno secondo le stime del
world economic forum il 65 per cento dei
bambini che oggi vanno le scuole
elementari svolgeranno un lavoro che
oggi ancora non esiste
io mi occupo di questi temi ne ha tanti
anni da quando all'università come voi
ho scelto non una facoltà scientifica
monomania stica ciò di studiare
sociologia del lavoro e oggi dopo più di
vent anni di studio di lavoro e di
esperienze concrete come manager come
coach come trainer ho provato ad
individuare tre macro direttrici 3
frontiere del lavoro che ci possono
aiutare ad affrontare questi
interrogativi e che ho sintetizzato in
tremato dimensioni appunto creatività
emotività e diversità
vorrei fare con voi un gioco che dovrà
durare pochissimi secondi
siete pronti allora provate ad
immaginare una frontiera vi dovete
focalizzare solo sulla prima immagine
che mi è venuta in mente e adesso
provate a visualizzarla ea
rappresentarla nella vostra mente che
cosa avete disegnato avete disegnato un
confine che divide o un luogo di
condivisione
avete immaginato dei confinanti o dei
confinati avete immaginato un recinto o
un orizzonte
sì perché le frontiere se da una parte
possono chiudere ma dall'altro possono
sottintendere anche espansione possono
essere un limite ma anche un'opportunità
per andare
le frontiere possono essere il luogo
delle avanguardie
quando parliamo di un'architettura di
frontiera di un linguaggio di frontiera
di uno spirito di frontiera
intendiamo proprio questo e che cos'è la
vanguardia
io la vorrei definire la flessibilità
della mente
quindi esistono delle frontiere senza
confini
sì esistono e sono le frontiere della
conoscenza il gioco abbiamo fatto serve
proprio per riflettere sulle differenze
tra le frontiere della creatività e la
creatività di frontiera
avete messo di limiti alla vostra
creatività o l'avete liberata e ripeto
di creatività proprio perché come vi ho
detto all'inizio è la prima frontiera
che ci può aiutare ad affrontare il
nostro futuro proprio perché oggi il
lavoro si divide in tre macro categorie
abbiamo il lavoro manuale il lavoro
intellettuale esecutivo e il lavoro
intellettuale e creativo e se il lavoro
manuale e sempre più delegato il ribot e
se il lavoro intellettuale esecutivo
viene sempre più assorbito dalle
tecnologie digitali e lo sarà sempre di
più dallo sviluppo dell'intelligenza
artificiale
cos'è che resterà le future generazioni
il lavoro intellettuale creativo che
sensazione vida a questo scenario
positiva o negativa
certo chi vedrà scomparire il proprio
lavoro vedrà e vivrà una situazione di
sconforto e quindi come ci possiamo
attrezzare che strumenti abbiamo a
disposizione per affrontare questo avrà
sicuramente sarà necessario un
cambiamento individuale di paradigma un
cambiamento al nostro main set perché
ciascuno di noi indipendentemente dal
lavoro che svolge dovrà d'ora in poi
porsi costantemente tre interrogativi
come sarà il mio lavoro fra tre anni
come sa come evolverà fra 5 e fra 10
esisterà ancora il lavoro che oggi
svolgo in questo credo che l'arte in
tutte le sue diverse espressioni ci può
aiutare perché dobbiamo provare
immaginarci come uno scrittore che deve
ogni volta scrivere
il nuovo nuovo libro come un regista che
deve immaginare una nuova pièce teatrale
scrivere una sceneggiatura girare un
nuovo film
quindi credo che noi abbiamo veramente
una bellissima opportunità davanti a noi
quella di poterci finalmente dedicare
alla parte più bella del lavoro e delle
gare alle macchine la parte ripetitiva e
noiosa e questo però che cosa significa
che dobbiamo imparare a scrivere il
nostro futuro ad immaginarlo a
visualizzarlo
ma soprattutto a riscriverlo
continuamente in questo ci può essere
d'aiuto
un racconto di borges la rosa di fare
sesso quando l'allievo chiedo al maestro
se esiste il paradiso e l'allievo gli
risponde sì il paradiso esiste e quindi
il maestro dice questa nostra terra
allora l'allievo chiedo ancora al
maestro se esiste l'inferno è il maestro
risponde sì l'inferno esiste e consiste
nel non accorgersi che che viviamo nel
paradiso
allora ancora l'allievo che dal maestro
quale sia la meta è il maestro gli
risponde ogni passo è la meta questa
cosa significa che dobbiamo essere
ottimisti ma dobbiamo essere degli
ottimisti attrezzati degli ottimisti
equipaggiati a vivere questo vortice di
cambiamenti costanti e quindi se come ci
insegna borghese ogni passo e la meta
allora vuol dire che passo dopo passo
dobbiamo diventare come dei bravi
alpinisti che affrontano la nuova
montagna da scalare
solo con tutto l'equipaggiamento
necessario per poterlo fare
se ci pensiamo le professioni che
saranno più facilmente automatizzate
saranno quelle che hanno obiettivi molto
limitati e modalità ben specifiche per
poterli raggiungere
mentre sarà molto più difficile
automatizzare quelle professioni che
richiedono competenze creative
competenze interdisciplinari
intelligenza emotiva e sociale punto i
tre driver che vi citavo all'inizio
creatività
emotività e diversità fede il mondo
agricolo
la coscienza umana è stata dominata
dalla fede e se il mondo industriale è
stato governato dalla ragione
la società postindustriale si fonderà
sull'empatia ossia quella capacità degli
esseri umani di mettersi in connessione
emotiva e dello stato d'animo delle
altre persone che cosa significa questo
dal punto di vista lavorativo
vi faccio un esempio oggi noi con un
click possiamo accedere a milioni di
brani musicali milioni di libri a
milioni di film e poi c'è il problema il
problema è catturare l'attenzione delle
persone coinvolgerle quindi la sfida di
qualsiasi lavoro nel futuro sarà proprio
il coinvolgimento e che cos'è il
coinvolgimento il coinvolgimento e
interazione il coinvolgimento è
attrazione il coinvolgimento è
esperienza e creare coinvolgimento è un
misto di arte e scienza e sicuramente le
neuroscienze c'è ci aiuteranno
tantissimo ma non saranno sufficienti da
sole sarà sempre necessario alla
creatività umana nel saper disegnare
nuovi modi per coinvolgere il pubblico
sarà sempre necessario pensare in
maniera radicalmente diversa gli oggetti
le esperienze le organizzazioni sulla
base delle emozioni che vorremmo far
suscitare alle persone e questo non
varrà solo per le esperienze fisiche ma
varrà anche per le esperienze virtuali
pensate quanto importante nelle commerce
creare esperienze ingaggiati i siti che
riusciranno a vendere di più saranno
quelli che riusciranno a trasformarsi in
luoghi di ritrovo tra persone
appassionate di quei prodotti dove loro
potranno votare commentare recensire
caricare contenuti
stringere amicizie scegliere attivamente
i prodotti che vogliono l'acquista sarà
una sorta di social shopping game dove
la relazione emotiva sarà al centro di
tutto la dimensione del gioco diventerà
uno strumento fondamentale per suscitare
emozioni e creare coinvolgimento quindi
la seconda dimensione di cui vi ho
parlato all'inizio che quella
dell'emotività ma queste tre dimensioni
appunto creatività diversità emotività
sono anche fondamentali per sviluppare
le famose soft skills immagino che oggi
quando voi dovete affrontare un
colloquio è la prima cosa che vi dicono
sono in pole indipendentemente dalle
competenze che ciascuno di noi ha
e queste tre dimissioni sono poi tra
l'altro strettamente connesse tra di
loro
la creatività che possiamo
sinteticamente definire la sintesi di
fantasia e concretezza e sempre e
costantemente deve essere nutrita dalle
emozioni ma non solo da quelle ma anche
dalla diversità e questo ce lo dimostra
per esempio sia la natura che la storia
la natura perché perché qualsiasi
ecosistema e quelli più vitali sono
quelli che hanno al proprio interno una
grande biodiversità ce lo insegna anche
la storia
pensate agli imperi le civiltà della
storia che sono state più vitali sono
quelli che avevano una varietà etnica e
religiosa al proprio interno possiamo
citare solo come esempio quella che è
stata la fioritura tecnico scientifica
dei regni alieni sti c che sono stati
proprio il frutto dell'incontro tra la
cultura greca e il sapere
ultramillenario degli esiti dei persiani
e pensiamo a cosa è stata alessandra una
città del mediterraneo dove conviveva
egizi greci siciliani ebrei è e che ha
dato i natali a grandi geni ricordiamo
ilkley del più grande matematico della
storia o la grande scienziata ipazia e
se oggi andiamo in silicon valley quello
che ci colpisce di più è il melting pot
di diverse nazionalità dove ribolliscono
talento e creatività ma che facciamo
oggi noi per promuovere la creatività
dei bambini nelle scuole
cosa facciamo per nutrire la loro
intelligenza emotiva e sociale
ancora oggi i bambini vengono visti come
dei contenitori da riempire da riempire
di nozioni e soprattutto in italia
abbiamo perso una straordinaria
opportunità che si chiama maria
montessori una donna straordinaria che
agli inizi del 900 ha elaborato dei
metodi educativi rivoluzionari che
mettevano al centro il bambino la
promozione della sua creatività
attraverso che cosa attraverso la
scoperta del talento naturale del
bambino della sua vocazione autentica
attraverso l'educazione
contemporaneamente si alle regole alla
responsabilità ma contemporaneamente
alla libertà
non a caso il suo metodo già all'inizio
del novecento avuto un'eco straordinario
negli stati uniti e in tutto il mondo e
oggi negli stati uniti abbiamo migliaia
di scuole montessori
a differenza di pochissime centinaia che
ci sono in italia e non è un caso che i
giovani imprenditori della silicon
valley quelli che hanno la maggioranza
di quelli che hanno trasformato la
cultura digitale del mondo sono stati
tutti allievi di scuole montessori
parliamo dei fondatori di google di jeff
bezos fondatore di amazon
il creatore di wikipedia è tra l'altro
gli stessi più fondatori di di amazon
lo dicono lo stesso in un in un libro
raccontano che quando si sono incontrati
a stanford si sono riconosciuti proprio
perché allievi di una scuola montessori
proprio perché educati in maniera
completamente diversa e quando hanno
dovuto progettare gli uffici di google
in california hanno voluto proprio
ricreare quelle modalità che loro hanno
sperimentato in quelle scuole mettendo
innanzitutto al centro il gioco come
strumento fondamentale per promuovere il
pensiero divergente e il pensiero
creativo oppure facciamo degli altri
esempi bimbi al bimbi è
un'organizzazione esponenziale così come
la definisce salemi smile il fondatore
della singolarità di university
ma al di là della definizione che lui da
esponenziale che oggi è stata anche
ripresa in varie occasioni ma che una
persona sceglie di di affittare una casa
di airbnb a parità di prezzo rispetto a
un hotel fatto per l'emozione e per il
diverso diverso calore che ti da vivere
e passare una vacanza in una casa
rispetto ad una 3 ma soprattutto alle
strisce vt dai proprietari di quella
casa che ti fanno sentire a casa tua
anche in un paese straniero anche
facebook è un esempio super citato di
organizzazione esponenziale ma se vi
ricordate sicuramente l'avete visto
tutti i film dei social network che
racconta la parabola di ascesa di
facebook vi ricordate zuckerberg
con in maniera ma in maniera quasi
istintiva utilizzo le nuove tecnologie
per dare una risposta a un bisogno umano
di restare in contatto con le altre
persone di reperire facilmente
informazioni sugli altri di crearsi una
rete virtuale che sopperisca i buchi di
quella reale e facebook
il risultato il cocktail psico emotivo
di fattori puramente motivi
vi ricordate se zuckerberg non fosse
stato lasciato dalla fidanzata
dovremo farci lasciare tutti i giorni
anche noi da fidanzati sepolta questi
risultati
se zucchero perché non fosse stato
escluso da tutti i club più esclusivi di
harvard quindi aveva c'era anche un
riscatto
insomma che doveva doveva vivere allora
lui è inventato proprio in una società
facciamo quella studentesca dove era
tutto gerarchicamente stratificato un
sistema orizzontale relazionale dove
tutto è accessibile a tutti ed è questo
poi il cambiamento di paradigma che
devono che devono vivere anche tutte le
organizzazioni oggi passa dal modello
verticale a quello orizzontale
collaborativo le tre dimensioni
le ricordo creatività emotività e
diversità
io credo che non solo continueranno ad
essere centrali fra 30 anni si vivremo
ancora in un'economia basata sul lavoro
ma lo saranno ancora di più se fra
trent'anni
vivremo una società basata sul tempo
libero e quindi se prevarrà la famosa
teoria del jobs del jobless croce cioè
lo sviluppo senza lavoro quindi se la
tecnologia distruggerà più il lavoro di
quello che sarà in grado di creare si
porrà il problema politico di
redistribuzione della ricchezza e dei
benefici prodotti ma si vorrà anche un
problema sociale di come gestire il
tempo libero di tutte quelle persone che
avranno
scherza ma non avendo un lavoro devono
dare un senso alla loro esistenza
allora quindi credo che ancor di più per
quelle persone che avranno il diritto di
consumare ma non il diritto di produrre
le le caratteristiche e dimensioni
saranno ancor più fondamentali della
creatività dell'emotività e della
diversità
grazie
[Applauso]